ever since making appearance on the face
of the earth
man has painstakingly been learning
about everything around
but even now several hundreds of
thousands of years later
we still cannot claim with certainty
that our nearest space objects have been
studied well enough
and probably the process of studying
them will continue for many a century
as we look further from our system we
can observe
objects that really defy our
understanding and i
invite you to join me on a journey to
several of these
we will fly by myra talk about brown and
black dwarves
take a look at canis venetici the
methuselah star
the exoplanet's glieser 832c
and last but not least witness the most
tremendous explosions that have ever
taken place in the observable universe
a fascinating journey is up ahead let's
get started
cosmo the first in outer space
most stars in the milky way slowly
revolve around the center
of the galaxy their appearance is rather
recognizable and their speed is
approximately the same as that of
interstellar gas
our sun for example passes through the
local interstellar cloud at a speed of
about 25 kilometers per
second but myra really stands out in
this respect
as it whizzes through gas in
interstellar space at a speed of 130
kilometers per second
as a result of such staggering
propulsion the shed material is blown
back
thus forming the unique tale we can
marvel at
this tale is the feature that makes myra
one of the most peculiar stars in the
cetus constellation
the tail of this star was discovered in
2007 with the help of the galex
orbiting ultraviolet space telescope
a group of astronomers received high
quality ultraviolet light images of mira
where the tail made up of gas and dust
can be clearly
seen at first this tail formation rather
perplexed the scientists
as the star had been under observation
for over 400 years
and no tail had been spotted before but
the riddle was soon solved
only ultraviolet images were able to
reveal the tail
and only regular photos had been taken
before
the length of the tail reaches 13 light
years
which is three times the distance from
the sun to the closest star
proxima centauri as i've already
mentioned
it was formed by material being shed in
the course of the star's movement
through space
every 10 years myra sheds approximately
as much material as the mass of our
earth
by estimating the length of the tail and
the star's velocity
the material found at the very tip of
the tail was gauged to have been dumped
as long ago as about 30
000 years as for the total mass of the
material shed so far
it may be as much as three thousand
earth masses
marvelous as it is the tail isn't the
only feature that singles out
mira among other stars another feature
it has is a bizarre formation that can
also be seen in images beamed back from
the galax telescope
it most likely originated as a result of
myra's speed with which it travels
through the molecular cloud
a kind of bow we can see in front would
have been accumulated in the many years
as a result of the stars material at the
front colliding with particles of
interstellar gas
that makes myra resemble a boat cutting
through water
only myra cuts through space instead
most of the shed material is made up of
atoms of hydrogen
once shed they gradually lose their
impetus and release the energy in the
form of ultraviolet rays
and it is these rays that were captured
by the galax telescope
we know mira as a binary pulsating
variable star
in its maximal luminosity periods it
flares up to be the brightest star in
its constellation
but even with its luminosity at its
lowest it can still be seen through
regular binoculars
the best time for observing it from our
earth is october and november
billions of years ago this object used
to be a yellow dwarf
and today myra's stellar travels are
coming to an end
as it is now in one of the final stages
of a star's life
speaking about its system it comprises
two stellar companions
mira a a red giant and myra b
a white dwarf both objects are about 417
light years away from our earth
and the distance between the companions
themselves is 70 astronomical units
the first component in the system is a
pulsating variable star
with the average apparent magnitude 3.5
depending on the phase however the value
may fluctuate between 10
and 2.
just to compare the apparent magnitude
of sirius
is -1.46
the mass of the system's first component
is approximately 1.2 that of the sun
interestingly its radius is 360 times
that of the sun
the reason for such impressive
dimensions and a comparatively small
mass
lies in the fact that since mira a is a
red giant
its average density may be thousands of
times less than that of water
just to compare the average density of
the sun is slightly bigger than that of
water
besides a star hitting the red giant
phase gets a massive growth spurt
and with a mass comparable to that of
the sun may in theory grow to the size
of the earth's orbit
the surface temperature on mira a
reaches 3000 degrees kelvin
the luminosity of the star meanwhile is
nine thousand times that of the sun
as for its supposed age it is estimated
to be
six billion years the red giant is not
massive enough to go supernova at the
end of its life
cycle instead it is going to expel its
outer envelope and gradually turn into a
white dwarf
the expanding outer envelope forms a
planetary nebula which will later on be
dispersed in space around it
as for the second component mira b it is
a white dwarf already
as this object is located close to mira
a by space standards
it attracts material dumped from the
outer layers of the red giant
in this manner a hot accretion disk was
formed around mirabi
and since mata is shed onto it at
irregular intervals
mira b is a variable star too its
apparent
magnitude fluctuates between 9.5 and 12.
[Music]
thus both components in the system are
variable stars
or variables other stars in the universe
whose luminosity depends on physical
processes taking place in their vicinity
also fall into the same category
it is important to study these objects
in order to understand the nature of
stellar evolution
as variable stars are more often than
not at a turning point in their
existence
in fact the phenomenon of myra is a
perfect demonstration of how objects
reaching some milestone or rather in
their life
may conceal a number of great riddles
myra's unusual features allowed
scientists to use it as the prototype
for a special classification for such
like objects that got the name
mira type stars or mira variables
celestial objects of this variety are
pulsating
variable stars of late type spectral
classes
with the values for their apparent
magnitudes ranging from 2.5 to 11.
mira variables are giants that shed
their router envelope in the course of
several million years
and eventually turn into white dwarfs
mostly mira type variables shouldn't be
heavier than two masses of the sun
although they may be thousands of times
brighter than the sun
on account of their expanded outer layer
the pulsation of these objects
occurs due to regular contraction and
expansion of these stars
this also causes changes in the radius
and temperature
resulting in variable luminosity as for
the chance of planets possibly hiding
somewhere in these stars orbits only one
myra type variable boasts an unconfirmed
planetary system
are leonis in the leo constellation
it goes without saying that the
information about myra possessed by
science today is rather sparse
we really have no clue if there are
planets or some equally amazing space
objects located close to it but it is
safe enough to say that this star
is yet to hit the headlines and for all
we know it may happen literally
at any moment
it may be hard to imagine but our sun
which is relatively small for a star is
heavier than any of 95 percent of stars
in the universe
there are also such things as red
dwarves 11 times
lighter than our host star however
they're actually not the lightest
objects out there
in the wide range between gas giants and
the smallest stars in the universe
there are some fascinating objects known
as brown dwarves
or dwarf stars
to understand their nature let's have a
look at how a star is born
according to modern scientific theories
stars and brown dwarves originate in the
same star nursery
when nebulae made up of interstellar gas
gradually contract
under the influence of gravitational
forces pressure and temperature inside
the gas increase
the enormous nebulae disintegrate into a
great number of proto-stellar discs
and each of them has a chance of
becoming a fully fledged star at some
point
its destiny depends on how much matter
the young star will manage to
capture
if the mass of a protest star is over 8
of that of the sun
thermonuclear reactions are bound to
start in its interior
nuclei of light elements like hydrogen
deuterium
helium or lithium blend together
emitting a great amount of heat
this heats up the interior of the future
star even more
and more and more matter is involved in
these processes
this unleashes a chain reaction which
may persevere for billions of years
until the substances fueling it are
totally depleted
and so and youth star is born somewhere
light years away from us
and can probably be observed in the sky
its future depends on its mass
and chemical composition most of its
life cycle will be spent in the main
sequence phase
later the star is likely to turn into a
white dwarf
or alternatively a neutron star or a
black hole
but what if the mass of the forming
protest star is smaller
then the gravitational pressure will not
be enough for the heat produced by the
thermonuclear reaction to increase the
star's temperature to the point
when it is able to sustain the burning
process without additional help from
other sources
nuclear fusion will still take place but
the heat emitted during the process will
not be enough for the star to flare up
instead the object will slowly decay
until the substances necessary for
thermonuclear reactions are depleted
it's worth mentioning that every kind of
reaction requires a certain temperature
to initiate nuclear fusion
if the star's temperature is lower
nuclei will not be able to get closer
and will be mutually repelled by coulomb
force
the celestial object we're looking at
today is what is known as a brown dwarf
in space
interestingly in spite of their name not
many of them are actually of a brownish
hue
if we could look at them with a naked
eye we would most likely see them
crimson
orange or even black the color depending
on the surface temperature
the hottest brown dwarfs have a
temperature not higher than 3000 degrees
kelvin which corresponds to a faint red
glow
most of them are much colder from 300 to
a couple of thousand degrees kelvin
the peak in their radiation is in the
infrared range which is invisible to the
naked eye
just to compare the coolest star's
surface temperature
is about 4000 degrees kelvin
by radiating heat into its environment a
brown dwarf gradually depletes its
energy and cools off
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
die down
and the object turns into a ball of
compressed gas
it will cool off gradually and will
resemble a gas giant of impressive
dimensions
after its heat is slowly dissipated a
brown dwarf may in theory cool off to as
little as four
or five degrees kelvin the background
temperature of the universe's relic
radiation
however the temperature of the coolest
space objects of this variety that have
been discovered are about 300 degrees
kelvin
there are several celestial objects that
may yet earn the title of a brown dwarf
one of them is wise 1828 plus 2650
it is in the lyra constellation and is
47 light years away from the sun
it is considered the coldest brown dwarf
to have been discovered
although astronomers make scientific
contributions every day
and perhaps we will soon hear of still
cooler objects
a brown dwarf's dimensions are usually
comparable to those of jupiter
while its mass is several dozen times
that of jupiter
for example the object choro 3b in the
constellation aquila
about 2 200 light years from the earth
is similar to jupiter in its diameter
but is 22 times heavier
a space object qualifies to be called a
brown dwarf if its mass is approximately
12 and a half to 80
times that of jupiter
objects heavier than that are red
dwarves those lighter than that
are sub-brown dwarfs super jupiters and
planimos
it goes without saying that such small
and dim celestial bodies are practically
impossible to see with a regular
telescope
the existence of these fascinating
objects was predicted back in the 1960s
although even special infrared detectors
were unable to spot brown dwarves for a
long time
many years passed before the first brown
dwarf had been detected
the great event took place in 1995.
the find was an object dubbed teda 1 a
rather hot celestial body for its class
it is located in the constellation
taurus approximately 400 light years
away from the sun
its surface temperature reaches 2700
degrees kelvin
and its mass is 55 times that of jupiter
or 5.2 percent that of the sun
in the years that followed a great
number of other celestial bodies of this
class were discovered
about 100 of them were detected within
as little a radius as 60 light years
from the sun
the total number of brown dwarves in our
galaxy is estimated at 50 to 100 billion
which accounts for about a quarter of
the overall number of stars in the milky
way
the brown dwarf closest to the earth is
just nine light years away from the sun
brown dwarves are rather cool objects by
stellar standards
that is why they may contain complex
compounds like methane
as for the temperature of the coolest
main sequence stars
it is so high that electrons leave their
nuclei
and thus the substance turns into
scorching plasma
even the simplest two atom molecules
like hydrogen
cannot endure this harsh environment
there may be planets orbiting brown
dwarfs
the first satellite of this kind was
detected in 2004
it orbits 2m1207
a comparatively warm brown dwarf in the
constellation centauri
which is 64.6 or 209 light years away
from the earth
this planet is rather large its mass is
four times that of jupiter
can the planets orbiting brown dwarfs be
habitable
it is positive that the chances are slim
but theoretically it is feasible
since brown dwarves are much cooler than
stars their habitable zone is narrower
concentrating closer to the parent dwarf
also it should be noted that the
eccentricity of the satellite
planet's orbit should be low that is
practically ideally spherical in shape
since a brown dwarf is constantly in the
process of cooling
its habitable zone gradually shifts
closer to it
according to some estimates a rather
heavy and hot dwarf may sustain
conditions
suitable for life on its satellite
planet for as long as 10 billion years
but of course there are admittedly many
other objects in the universe
which are definitely more favorable for
cultivating life
the term stellar evolution in astronomy
refers to the sequence of changes that a
standard goes throughout its entire life
this process largely depends on the
object's initial mass
and may take anything from several
million to tens of billions of years
as a rule a star originates from a cloud
of code low pressure interstellar gas
due to gravitational instability the
cloud compresses
and eventually slowly assumes a
spherical shape during the compression
process the gravitational field energy
is transformed into heat and radiation
with the temperature of the young star
gradually going up
the duration of this stage depends
directly on the star's initial mass
with the heaviest stars it may take
about a hundred thousand years
and with the lightest ones the phase may
last up to several billion years
our sun's mass for instance is
comparatively small and so it remained
in this first
phase for approximately 110 million
years
in the next phase after a sufficiently
high temperature has been reached to the
core
thermonuclear fusion takes place inside
the star
and the compression ceases after this
the processes taking place at the core
become the star's only energy source and
thus
a young star which is also called a
protester becomes a main sequence
star this is the starting point for
calculating a star's
age as this phase accounts for
approximately ninety percent of its life
cycle
our sun for example will remain in the
main sequence stage for approximately
eleven and a half
billion years
a star enters its main sequence stage
its chemical composition is still very
close to interstellar environment
and is 91 hydrogen at the same time the
process of hydrogen transforming into
helium is constantly in progress
inside the star as a result the core
compresses and gains in density
which gradually increases the rate of
chemical reactions
it leads to noticeable changes in the
star's properties
for example the luminosity of our sun in
the main sequence stage
accounted for only 70 percent of its
luminosity today
by the time the stage is over the
luminosity is going to be 2.2 times that
of today
it should be mentioned that not all
stars make it to the main sequence stage
the exceptions known to science today
are referred to as code and hot
subdwarves
these objects are very similar to main
sequence stars but they do differ
from them thus by contrast sub dwarves
are not rich in heavy elements
and are not so luminous the final phase
for main sequence stars
also depends on their mass generally a
star either discards its outer coat thus
becoming a white dwarf
or goes supernova to later become a
neutron star or a black hole
a supernova is a phenomenon when a
star's luminosity dramatically
intensifies
with great amounts of energy released
during the process
after that the flare slowly fades
this explosion is accompanied by
emissions of great amounts of matter
from the outer coat
the remaining mata in the core of the
star god supernova
generally forms a compact object either
a neutron star
or a black hole apart from everything
else
the matter released in the course of a
supernova event
contains products of thermonuclear
synthesis
it is thanks to these elements that the
universe is able to evolutionize
chemistry wise
if a star's mass doesn't quite reach
eight sun masses however
this main sequence star will end up
being a white dwarf
that is an object which is a hot
celestial body of small dimensions
and a high density for instance in the
case with our sun
when the time comes for it to go through
this phase it is going to become a
hundred times
smaller than it is now white dwarfs do
not generate energy and are luminous
only on account of their high
temperature
even though the hottest white dwarfs
surfaces may be as scorching as 70 000
kelvins
due to their small size their luminosity
is not that great
as for their average density it is
almost a million times that of the
regular density of main sequence stars
these objects consist for the most part
of a plasma of nuclei and electrons
and a completely devoid of thermonuclear
energy sources
which is why they gradually cool off and
assume a red hue
sirius b is the closest white dwarf to
us that we currently know of
and it is 8.6 light years away
this object's mass is give or take that
of the sun
and is considered to be one of the most
massive white dwarfs known today
its volume is a millionth of that of the
sun and its dimensions are identical to
those of our earth
sirius b is believed to have become a
white dwarf approximately 120 million
years ago
with the initial mass of the star in its
main sequence phase having been
five sun masses today it is posited that
these objects account for three to ten
percent of the overall stellar
population of our galaxy
according to different estimates over 97
percent of the stars known today
are eventually destined to become white
dwarfs
as time goes by these objects are bound
to cool off and fade
eventually all celestial bodies of this
variety will become black dwarves
which implies that they will completely
cease to emit any visible light
this process takes scores of billions of
years
that is why to date science hasn't had a
chance to observe any of these objects
the universe is considered to be too
young to have produced any black dwarves
at this point but scientists have
already managed to spot objects quite
similar to them
whose temperature has gone down lower
than 4000
kelvins these objects are white dwarfs
wd0346 plus
246 and sdss j110 217
a black dwarf is what most stars look
like at the final stage of their
revolution
its mass is quite identical to that of a
white dwarf
according to today's models
demonstrating cooling of these bodies
white dwarfs formed in the course of the
evolution of the first generation of
stars are supposed to have a temperature
of approximately 3
200 kelvins and to appear as rather dim
objects for all we know
these celestial bodies could be part of
the universe's hidden mass
components for a white dwarf to cool off
to the temperature as low as 5 kelvins
it may take approximately 1 quadrillion
years
in theory when black dwarves cool off
completely
the process of dark matter annihilation
becomes very important for their
existence
this phenomenon hasn't been directly
observed in the universe yet
although it is thought that in the
course of annihilation particles of dark
matter will form
ordinary photons and emit light visible
through a telescope
without allowing for this phenomenon
black dwarves are believed to cool off
and
fade to the point where their
temperature equals the background
temperature of the universe
however in theory thanks to the energy
derived from dark matter annihilation
black dwarves may well continue to
radiate energy for a considerably longer
period
and thus enjoy their luminosity longer
the process of dark matter annihilation
in these objects is thought to continue
for as long as the galactic halo remains
whole
and that means for over a septillion
years
after that dark matter annihilation
gradually ceases
and only then will black dwarves cool
off completely
it is likely that mankind will never be
able to discover objects of this kind
as the main period of their life takes
place in the face and the life of our
universe
which will come after the one we are in
at the moment the period we live in is a
starry park
that is the period where stars are still
born quite actively
this epoch will last up until the point
when the galaxies will deplete all of
their interstellar gas
after that it will be the turn of low
mass stars like our sun
to fade following that a long period of
disintegration will begin
when white brown and black dwarves are
the main objects populating the universe
at the next stage the epoch of black
holes
all matter in the universe will be
transformed into elementary or subatomic
particles
with the remaining black dwarves getting
sucked in by black holes or completely
disintegrating
the final stage in the life of the
universe is supposed to be the epoch of
eternal darkness
where there won't be any energy sources
whatsoever in space
the overall temperature in the universe
will reach absolute zero
space will gradually expand and in the
light of the last and rare black holes
in about one google years our world will
come to its gloomy
end by that time all traces of what was
once the human civilization
would have become nothing
however if we can influence the process
of the universe's evolution
in any way the course of its life may be
significantly altered
just imagine what a stupendous portion
of our cultural heritage
would never have been around a great
number of myths and legends
have to do with the stars it goes
without saying that any travels to other
stellar systems would be out of the
question
even a few light years is an
overwhelming distance for man
even at this point of our scientific
progress as for covering
several hundred million light years the
mere
thought is no more than just a fanciful
dream
it would take man inventing extremely
powerful and advanced telescopes to be
able to see that the sun was not the
only star in our universe
but would they ever be invented there is
no way of finding it out
especially if we take into account the
fact that it is stars themselves that
have always been a powerful stimulus for
man to try to get to the bottom of the
nature of the universe
chances are that a bleak dark sky would
never have fascinated people
and as a result no modern devices and
equipment for
observing space would ever have been
developed
in one of our previous videos i've
already told you about gargantuar and
cosmic voids
or else i take it you would have heard
about these
voids a large-scale expanses of space
that are almost
or completely devoid of galaxies or
galaxy clusters
these enormous objects take up about 50
percent of the observable universe
the average void measures approximately
40 megaparsec
or 130 million light years however the
diameter of champion voids
may reach several hundred million or
even a billion light years
these extra large voids are rather
predictably referred to as supervoids
the density of matter in these regions
is much less than in other areas of the
universe
and accounts for less than ten percent
of the average density in meta galaxy
voids are the largest formations among
the large-scale structures of the
universe
on a par with galactic filaments or
thread-like formations
cosmology today explains their existence
by diversity of matter when the universe
was formed
one of the largest voids ever discovered
is the canis veneticis supervoid
spotted in 1988 this supervoid is the
second largest void
known to science today with a diameter
measuring a staggering 300
to 400 megaparsec or a billion light
years
the canis venetici supervoid is located
1.5 billion light years away from our
earth
interestingly just 17 galaxy clusters
are located in this area of
mind-boggling dimensions and this is
extremely little for such an incredibly
enormous
expansive space all the 17 clusters are
gathered within a comparatively small
area
by space standards namely within a
measly 150 million light years
if any gravitational interaction between
them does take place
more advanced technologies are called
for to detect it
the diameter of the canis venetici
supervoid
accounts for approximately one percent
of that of the observable universe
it could easily accommodate ten thousand
galaxies
identical to the milky way in terms of
dimensions
who knows perhaps there are life forms
on a planet hidden somewhere in these 17
clusters
however there is no way light from our
sun will ever reach those parts
and any interaction with potential
inhabitants of those parts of the
universe is effectively
out of the question now what is a
billion light years
the history of multicellular life forms
on our earth
starting from primitive celentarate
animals counts just over 800 million
years
in other words life on our planets
evolved from colonies of protozoans to
humans
in the time a photon traveled from one
edge of the supervoid to the other
it takes some stars less time to
complete their entire life cycle
from getting born to going supernova or
finishing life in an
alternative way actually covering this
distance in a spaceship
romantic as it is sounds like a
recklessly eccentric idea
in order to understand what space inside
a void is like
you have to think of a deep physical
vacuum it may contain
interstellar gas clouds independent star
clusters or even galaxies
but most of the supervoid contains
nothing the name
is self-explanatory of course space
expenses are for the most part vacuum
just to give you an idea about the
proportions there is a cubic centimeter
of dense stellar matter to
thousands of cubic kilometers of space
but even this space is not completely
empty
a mark of a hundred kilometers above
ground is the accepted limit of the
earth's atmosphere
at this height the atmospheric pressure
is so small that it becomes comparable
to that of solar wind
however there is no clearly defined
transition to space
and even several hundred kilometers
above the earth's surface
that can be found an extremely small
amount of gas molecules from our
atmosphere
seemingly negligible these molecules
still
manage to slow down artificial
satellites orbiting our planet
as a result many of them have to
regularly adjust their
orbit in order not to lose their
momentum and not to have to get back to
earth prematurely
gas concentration is much lower the
further we are from a planet
but even beyond our solar system and
away from any star or planet
there will always be at least a few
molecules of hydrogen
in every cubic centimeter of space
in addition to that there will be solar
wind in space
a current of high energy subatomic
particles emitted by the sun
and of course other things have to be
reckoned with like radiation of distant
stars
relic radiation and neutrinos subatomic
particles particularly hard to detect
the vacuum inside the void is deep to
such a point that there is less than
half a molecule of matter for every
cubic centimeter of space
besides all sources of radiation are so
remote from it
that the density of their radiation is
quite negligible compared to relic
radiation
as a result all that remains is
undetectable neutrinos
and the cosmic microwave background
as i've mentioned before there is
something else to be found inside the
incredibly vast expanses of the void
apart from deep vacuum there are also
clouds of interstellar gas
the future nursery for stars and
galaxies
secondly dark matter is supposed to be
found inside
supervoids but today's methods of
detection are hardly adequate for
studying it
it should be noted that the overwhelming
majority of voids detected so far
are located hundreds of millions of
light years away from the solar system
in essence what we are observing now
is the distant past of these formations
only one void lies relatively close to
the local group of galaxies
among them the milky way and is referred
to as the local void
its diameter measures approximately 180
million light years
and the distance between the sun and the
void center is about
90 million light years
the boaters void is another large
formation about 700 million light years
away from the sun
the diameter of this void measures
approximately 330 million light years
which is about 0.35 percent of the
diameter of the observable universe
the boaters void was discovered in 1981
by a group of scientists headed by
robert kirschner
with theoretical arguments in favor of
the existence of supervoids having been
formulated 20 years previously
the supervoid is thought to have been
formed as a result of several smaller
voids blending together
just 60 galaxies have been pinpointed
inside the boaters void by now although
such staggering expanses could easily
have accommodated about two thousand
speaking about the most mysterious void
in the universe
it lies three billion light years away
from the sun
it is known as the cmb cold spot or the
iridonous supervoid
this supervoid is a champion even by
supervoid standards
with a diameter measuring 1.8 billion
light years
it may easily have accommodated 18 000
galaxies
similar to the milky way
the iridonous supervoids temperature is
from 70 to 150 degrees micro kelvin
colder than the average
cmb temperature of the universe
today's theory of the universe's origin
cannot give a definite explanation to
this fact
this so did not fit into the accepted
theory in cosmology
that at first the measurements were
dismissed as faulty and the equipment
was blamed
only after several years of scrupulous
measurement were the readings finally
accepted
a great number of explanations including
rather extravagant ones were offered
concerning the strange temperature
properties
one hypothesis has it that the
anomalously low cosmic microwave
background in the iridonous supervoid
is a result of the influence of
supermassive chunks of dark energy
according to another hypothesis this
area is what is left of another universe
that had existed before hours
be it as it may there is disappointingly
no definite answer yet
as i've already mentioned the universe
is over 13.8 billion years old
so how can it possibly contain a star
older than itself
for more than a hundred years
astronomers have been observing a
strange star 190 light years away from
the earth
in the constellation libra it travels at
a speed of about 1.3 million
kilometers per hour but its most
peculiar feature
is its age hd140283
is considered one of the oldest stars in
the universe
known to science today
in the year 2000 scientists tried to
estimate its
age they were guided by data that had
been collected by the hipparchus
satellite launched by the european space
agency
and thus they got the figure of 16
billion years
the generally accepted age of the
universe was 13.8 billion years
which had been confirmed by observations
the discrepancy between the two values
prompted a lot of debate how can a star
be older than the universe
or else how can the universe be younger
than a star
as for its unusual name the star was
dubbed after a biblical character
methuselah
who according to scripture lived to be
969 years old
the star methuselah is clearly genuinely
old
it is none other than a sub giant
consisting mainly of hydrogen and helium
it contains a negligible amount of iron
which may only mean that this object was
formed before
iron had become such a widespread
element but how can a star be about 2
billion years older than the environment
it finds itself in
it appeared to be a perplexing paradox
astronomer howard bond and his
colleagues from pennsylvania state
university
proceeded to double check the value of
the star's age
they too were struck by the fact that
methuselah had been born before the
universe
in their task they had to go through 11
observational data sets collected in the
period from 2003 to 2011 by the fine
guidance sensors of the hubble space
telescope the sensors measure stars
positions
distances and radiation energy it is
possible to produce precise results in
estimating the age of an object
by studying its parallax and using
spectroscopy and photometry
according to bond not knowing the
precise distance to hd140283
remained one of the reasons the age may
have been gauged wrongly
the distances had to be scrupulously
measured in order to calculate the
object's luminosity with a view to
estimating the object's age
the brighter the star the younger it
actually is
the scientists were also studying the
parallax and keeping watch on the star's
position in the sky for a year
theoretical models also left a lot to be
desired
the scientists were uncertain as to the
precise rate of nuclear reactions
and couldn't put their finger on the
role of diffusion of certain elements in
the star's outer layers
that is why the team considered the
possibility of a faster thermonuclear
synthesis
if the star really burned faster than
ordinary ones do
then it was supposed to be really
younger than previously estimated
bond added that oxygen at hd140283
also had to be reckoned with the ratio
of oxygen to iron was rather high
and in the first millions of years of
the universe's evolution
there wasn't that much oxygen around
this was another piece of evidence
confirming methuselah's younger age
eventually the value bond and his
colleagues produced was 14.46 billion
years
plus minus 800 million years
this of course is significantly less
than 16 billion
but still more than the age of the
universe not counting the margin of
error of 800 million years
according to robert matthews a british
physicist from aston university in
birmingham who wasn't on the research
team
the estimates may have been corrupted by
both accidental and systematic errors
the most precise up-to-date value of the
star's age was in conflict with the age
of the universe
calculated using relic radiation the
conflict could be resolved
only by giving the result the larger
margin of error
in later research the star was gauged to
be still younger
in 2014 a study titled sequel was
published
where the authors lowered the estimate
of methuselah's age to 14.27 billion
years
but admittedly there was still the
margin of error of seven
eight hundred million years
strangely the star's age still beat that
of the universe
according to bond the similarity between
the values of the age of the universe
and its oldest
star proves the consistency of the big
bang theory
besides the values were produced by
different methods of analysis
thanks to meticulous observations the
results are not as scattered as they
were in the 1990s when ancient stars
were estimated at 19 or even 20 billion
years
at least now the inaccuracies do not
clash with the accepted models
robert matthews however maintains that
the issue is anything but solved
as recently as in july 2019 scientists
participated in an international
cosmology conference at the calvary
institute for theoretical physics in
santa barbara
california where they analyzed studies
of the universe's supposed age
judging by the galaxy's nearest to us
the universe is several hundred million
years younger than suggested by the
results of relict radiation calculations
moreover for all we know our universe
may turn out to be just 11.4 billion
years old
and the new estimates shouldn't be
casually dismissed
after all one of the authors was a nobel
prize laureate
astrophysicist adam reece from the space
telescope science institute
sdsci the conclusions are drawn on the
concept of the universe's expansion
suggested by edwin hubble back in 1929
the expansion of the universe is a
fundamental concept in the big bang
theory
if the universe has always been
expanding shouldn't there be a starting
point for the process
that could be calculated
according to the latest data the rate of
expansion is in fact
10 percent higher than suggested by
planck
according to planck's team the rate of
the universe's expansion is 67.4
kilometers per second per megapasc
the latest measurements produce the
value of around 73.74 kilometers per
second per megapasc
rhys maintains that there should be a
difference between the real rate of
expansion today
and the rate implied by the physics of
the early universe
firstly it is obvious that accepted
theories have to be seriously questioned
and secondly there is the dark matter
and dark energy riddle
since the hubble constant produces a
bigger value for the rate of expansion
it suggests that the universe is younger
than we think
the 67.74 constant corresponds to the
age of 13.8 billion years
the 73 or even 77 constant corresponds
to the age of not more than 12.7 billion
years
quite recently a study was published in
the science magazine which claims the
hubble constant to be 82.4
it should be mentioned it's a
well-reputed magazine
the 82.4 constant corresponds to the age
of 11.4 billion years
either way the star hd 140283
still appears older than the universe
matthews believes this is a task to be
handled by cosmologists
rather than astrophysicists to define
the age precisely it isn't stars that
have to be studied
but more complex structures of the
universe
so why would the universe appear younger
than this one star
matthews suggests at least two possible
explanations
as is so often the case with the history
of science
the end result is likely to turn out to
be a combination of the two versions
in short there may be observation errors
caused by something we do not fully
understand
and also there may be some blanks in our
knowledge of the universe's dynamics
for example the dark matter force which
as it were has been in charge of the
expansion of the universe for billions
of years
is still rather baffling to us thus the
age paradox could well be accounted for
by dark energy variations
and changes in the expansion rate
according to theorists
all this may have to do with the
fundamentals of the nature of gravity
in particular the causal set theory
which leads us to believe that by
measuring gravitational waves
we may get to the bottom of the paradox
gravitational waves are hard to measure
just to give you an idea they were first
detected as recently as in 2015.
astrophysicists stephen feeney from the
flatiron institute believes that a major
scientific breakthrough on this front
may take place in the next thousand
years
and the bizarre phenomenon of the age of
hd140283
is bound to reveal larger and more
scientifically complex things
that are yet to be discovered and
explored
today we're able to access a lot of
information about space objects
discoveries in astronomy and studies of
prominent scientists
it is quite within our power to share
this information and bring as many
inquiring minds up to date as possible
this is a kind of landscape one would
see in the least harsh part of a planet
dubbed by scientists as super earth and
the closest potential candidate suitable
for searching for alien life forms
but let's be consecutive
the recent past heralded a boom in
discovering exoplanets
there are four thousand three hundred
seventy exoplanets discovered in over
three thousand planetary systems so far
in addition to these more than 3 000
objects are awaiting confirmation of
their exoplanet status
most of them are large bodies gas giants
super jupiters and super earths
this is accounted for by technical
features of the technologies used for
the purpose
it is easier to look for massive bodies
with a short orbital period than to try
to spot smaller planets similar to the
earth or mars in terms of dimensions
there are among exoplanets those that
may realistically harbor life
there are dozens of these objects
scattered in space
and they understandably draw scientists
close attention
today we're going to look at one of
these objects which is an exoplanet
dubbed gliese 832c
in fact this exoplanet is one of the
most likely places where
alien life forms will eventually be
detected
this exoplanet orbits a star called
glieser 832
which lies 16 light years away from the
sun and is part of the gru's
constellation
gliese 832 is a dim red dwarf
whose luminosity is just point seven
percent of that of the sun
both its mass and diameter are
approximately two times
smaller than those of the sun and its
temperature reaches about three thousand
three hundred degrees kelvin that is the
reason why the habitable zone of this
planet is within quite a short range
from its star
due to tidal forces the planets lying in
the habitable zone of gliese 832 will be
tidally locked to their star
that is will face the star with one side
only just as it is the case with the
moon and the earth
and mercury and the sun there are two
confirmed planets orbiting glieser 832
the jupiter-like planet glieser832b
was discovered first astronomers
announced the event in 2008.
with the mass two-thirds out of jupiter
the planet orbits parents start a
distance of an average
3.4 astronomical units completing a full
orbit
every 9.4 earth years
the discovery of the other confirmed
planet glieser 832c
was announced in 2015 by an
international team of scientists headed
by robert wittenberg
it got an exceptionally high rating for
its similarity to the earth
0.81 to be more exact which instantly
attracted both scientists and reporters
it was also nicknamed the second earth
even though the two planets parameters
are rather different
either way this is one of the planets
closest to the earth with such a high
earth similarity index
the mass of glieser 832c is five and a
half that of the earth
it takes the planet 35 earth days to
complete a full orbit around its parent
star
moving at a distance of an average 0.16
astronomical units
this is six times less than the distance
between our earth and the sun
its orbit's eccentricity is rather high
with the planet regularly leaving the
habitable zone
and then re-entering it this must cause
sharp temperature leaps and drops on its
surface
gliese 832c is estimated to receive
approximately as much energy flux from
its parent star as does the earth from
the sun
the average surface temperature on the
planet is 253 degrees kelvin or 20
degrees
celsius below zero it is also suggested
that due to the atmosphere which is
likely to be quite dense
the temperature on the planet may be
considerably higher
however it is not easy to claim this
with certainty
as gliese 832c lies quite close to its
star
and so chance's eye is firmly tidally
locked to it
in this case there should be a
substantial temperature difference
between its sunny side and shadow side
which should regularly cause hurricane
winds if the atmosphere really is
dense it's worth mentioning that in 2017
following observations astrophysicists
from the university of texas at
arlington the usa
put forward the hypothesis that there
may be a third planet in the glieser 832
system
its mass could be 1 to 15 earth masses
and it could follow a stable orbit
around the center of the system
0.25 to 2 astronomical units away from
it
at the moment the planet is being
searched for
let's imagine what gliese 832c would
look like
assuming life were possible on this
planet
first of all we wouldn't help noticing
its gravity
which would be strikingly higher than
that on our earth
since the planet's diameter is not yet
known the gravity force cannot be
calculated exactly
still it would be a rocky planet similar
to our earth and earth-like planets in
terms of its density
so its gravity force would be likely to
reach two to four hundred percent that
of the earth
this would lead to the relief leveling
out meaning that the mountains would not
be so high
and the ocean is not so deep this in its
turn would enhance the area of warm
water
which is favorable for life due to a
dense atmosphere and in comparatively
dim
sun the landscape on gliese 832c would
be of a reddish hue
and in general the planet would be
submerged in semi-darkness
since the planet is likely to face its
star with the same side at all times
the temperature on the sunny side should
be high and the temperature on the
shadow side
quite low in the ring-like area at the
border between them
the temperature should be moderately
comfortable although due to regular
heating of the planet the atmosphere
would be constantly in turmoil
which should result in strong winds in
addition
high objects of relief potentially able
to dissipate some of the force of
hurricane air currents fail to form on
account of high gravity conditions
as the orbit of gliese 832c is small and
elongated
seasons on this planet should change
every week it will be winter on gliese
832c at the furthest point from its
parent star
and summer at the closest approach the
tilt of the rotational axis with respect
to the ecliptic plane will not be of
such importance as it is in the case of
the earth
the change of season will depend
exclusively on the planets getting
closer to
or away from its parent star the most
favorable conditions for life to develop
on gliese 832c
are likely to be in the ring-like area
at the border between the light and the
dark sides of the planet
it is here that most liquid water will
accumulate
and rain down from clouds formed on the
warm side
ice caps on the dark side will also melt
in the border zone
thus supplying still more water it goes
without saying that it is water that is
key to developing life
the change of seasons will be likely to
play the same role as lunatides in our
earth
with areas alternately submerging and
re-emerging
this process of water getting mixed with
substances dissolved in it
is a good prerequisite for life to
originate and develop
there is a good chance of life
originating in water and probably
staying in it without later spreading to
land
the ocean reduces the effect of gravity
and protects its potential inhabitants
from sharp temperature changes and
hurricane winds
as for frequent and sharp changes of
seasons hypothetical organisms on gliese
832c may learn to lapse into a state of
anabiosis
in order to weather unpleasant or those
short periods of high and low
temperatures
alternatively they may choose to
emigrate to a comfortable temperature
zone from the sunny side to the shadow
side and back again for example
if a space probe ever reaches the
surface of gliese 832c
to investigate the area what would it
see there
assuming life did originate on this
planet as the gravity forces are rather
strong there
the potential inhabitant should be a
thick set chunky figure
boasting a robust skeleton and powerful
muscles
plants on gliese 832c would be dark
in order to attract as much light as
possible
they should also be quite low and likely
to be creeping or moss-like
with strong roots able to stand winds it
is highly likely that rather than
chlorophyll
some other molecules should be important
for photosynthesis
the planet's dense atmosphere may become
a habitat for bizarre life forms
floating in air currents
single-celled microorganisms for
instance may float in this dense
atmosphere following air currents
while capturing light and nutrients
dispersed in the air
because of a dense atmosphere high
clouds and a dim
sun the surface of gliese 832c would be
a rather dark place
life forms would have to adapt to these
conditions vision would probably not
play the decisive role in their
existence if it evolved at all
alternatively its spectrum may be
limited to the infrared
range be it as it may all these
speculations remain conjectures and
ideas
even though they're based on good
physical laws and assumptions
i wonder which of these suggestions you
would call realistic
and which of them bordering on fantasy
or perhaps
gliese 832c is not habitable at all
let us know in the comments and let's
keep in touch
to begin with let's define what the big
bang actually is
and estimate how much power may have
been released in this process
the concept of the phenomenon referred
to describes the accepted cosmological
model of the genesis and early life of
the universe
namely the beginning of the universe's
expansion
after an undefined period of being in
the state of singularity
the state of singularity is the state of
the universe when the density of energy
was large
and the space-time curve was sharp these
figures
reached the planck values the big bang
on the other hand
is said to have been the starting point
for the process of this energy getting
released
this event can't have been anything like
a dynamite stick going off an empty
space
besides it took place literally
everywhere at the same time
and it's hardly possible to pinpoint the
epicenter
it is indeed hardly possible to say with
certainty
how it really happened and what it
looked like
but one thing is clear this was an
ultimate event of enormous proportions
we're talking about an explosion that is
considered to have given birth to the
entire universe
in the centuries of the history of space
observation science hasn't registered
any other event
similar in its proportions however as
our technologies became more advanced
scientists came to realize that there is
some events taking place in deep space
which are powerful to such a point that
it appears that all existing models
need to be questioned one of these
breakthrough discoveries was gamma ray
bursts
or grbs the term traditionally refers to
large-scale energy emissions in space
which in fact are an everyday occurrence
in the cosmos
gamma-ray bursts are the most powerful
of explosions known to science
taking place in space shockingly
the energy released in a few seconds is
tantamount to that released by the sun
in the course of 10 billion years
it was next to impossible to register
gamma-ray bursts for 30 years
even though some attempts revealed a
rather exact location of a source
sources were always scattered and didn't
repeat in one place
a burst didn't leave any traces
whatsoever
and the best scientists could do was to
identify some really remote galaxy where
a burst was registered
only in 1968 was it possible for
scientists to put their finger on the
phenomenon of gamma-ray bursts
all thanks to the veiler satellites of
the us air force
whose mission was detecting possible
nuclear tests in the atmosphere
according to today's views gamma ray
bursts occur when massive stars go
supernova and collapse to black holes
a powerful stream of charged particles
bursts out from the hole's vicinity
on interacting with magnetic fields and
cosmic radiation
these particles produce gamma rays as a
result
this stream of gamma rays is powerful to
such a point that such events are easily
detected by satellites
even though they may have taken place
several billion light years away
on the other hand they can't be
registered by earth-based telescopes on
account of the atmosphere
which actively absorbs these rays
the amount of energy released in the
course of a gamma-ray burst
may reach acceptant decilion ergs
if an event of such tremendous
proportions were to take place close to
a planet
it would be tantamount to an atomic bomb
exploding in every hectare of the sky
of course all living things would almost
certainly die
instantly a gamma ray burst is capable
of exterminating any life within the
radius of tens
and even hundreds of light years and
seriously affecting biospheres of
planets within the radius of thousands
of light years
thankfully they occur a bigger distance
away from us
for example one of the most powerful
gamma-ray bursts ever detected
dubbed grb-180720
is more than 4 billion light-years away
from us
this means that its light has traveled
to our earth for about one third of the
universe's age
as for the amount of energy in this
gamma-ray burst it fluctuates between
200 to 1000 billion electron volts
just to compare the energy of visible
light is in the range from one
to three electron volts at a distance of
tens of thousands of light years a gamma
ray burst like that
is practically harmless but one out of a
hundred of thousand flares in a galaxy
may occur close enough to a planet to
pose a threat
speaking about a threat to our own
planet scientists are still at odds if
an explosion like that may dramatically
affect it
for example according to some
calculations
gamma ray bursts are really capable of
seriously and noticeably affecting the
earth's fauna every several hundred
million years
and one of these flares may have been
the cause of a major mass extinction
event
however science is more keen on
investigating the nature and origin of
such bursts
today it is posited that as a rule
gamma-ray bursts occur following the
collapse of a really massive star
or else when two neutron stars merge and
collapse together to a black hole
a gamma ray burst event doesn't much
differ from a supernova event in this
respect
as both of them involve a gravitational
collapse of a star's core
the difference lies in the consequences
in the case with a star-going supernova
a hard layer of matter's shed which
travels with a speed of 10 to 30
kilometers per second
as for a gamma-ray burst something
emitting gamma-quanta travels
practically at the speed of light
an event like that isn't likely to occur
anywhere close to us
be it as it may a great number of events
of a similarly large scale
occur in the cosmos and they may well
take place comparatively close to us
one of these could be a star-going
supernova a phenomenon when a star's
apparent magnitude intensifies
10 to 20 times this process is the
ultimate destructive event
taking place at the end of some star's
evolution and is accompanied by the
release of great amounts of energy
a supernova event is accompanied by
emissions of substantial amounts of
matter from the star's outer layer in
interstellar space
if the star's mass before the explosion
was more than eight sun masses
a compact object is formed from the
remaining matter of the star
this object is called a neutron star
if the star's mass was more than 40 sun
masses
it is positive that a black hole appears
after the explosion
as for the composition of these
emissions there's a large percentage of
thermonuclear synthesis products
the remains of the process taking place
throughout the star's entire life cycle
it is thanks to such supernovae that the
universe in general and every galaxy in
particular chemically evolved
it goes without saying that what i've
told you about the nature of these
events
is largely theoretical assumptions
man hasn't observed these processes from
up close
and therefore cannot make definite
statements about their nature
nevertheless thanks to the development
of astrophysics
science is advancing impressively far
ahead
revealing things unheard of in the past
and who knows as time goes by we will
probably get closer to understanding
much more complex matters
the list of puzzling celestial bodies in
space around us
may run endlessly the reason for that
is that science is still not able to
give a definite answer to how
fundamental things that the universe is
made up of
actually work the discovery of yet
another bizarre object
is a rule rather than exception and
until we find the key to our
understanding of the nature of all
anomalies lurking in space
the solutions of mysteries in the
universe will continue to elude us
and the thing that will remain for us to
do will be to keep getting back to them
trying to give them some description
[Music]
you